bonjour je suis olivier de montlivault
le dirigeant fondateur de sos
accessoires nous sommes une pme d'une
soixantaine de personnes nous sommes le
leader en france de l'auto réparation et
de la vente de pièces détachées pour
réparer les appareils électroménagers
cette élection présidentielle se déroule
très clairement dans un contexte où les
sujets économiques et écologiques sont
majeurs on parle de évidemment de la
question du pouvoir d'achat on parle de
l'avenir de notre environnement de notre
de notre planète chez sos accessoires
c'est au coeur de notre de notre
activité est au coeur de nos
problématiques le fait de réparer
permettrait largement
d'économiser à une partie de de nos
ressources de noah de nos salaires
ce que j'attends c'est que nos
gouvernants continuent à améliorer le
cadre
réglementaire l' indice de réparabilité
il faut l'étendre à beaucoup plus de
deux catégories il faut renforcer ses
critères il faut le pousser jusqu'à un
indice de durabilité c'est par exemple
peut-être de réfléchir à une limite une
diminution de la tva sur la réparation
ça va aussi dans le bon sens pour
l'autre balance commerciale parce qu'il
n'ya pas me sers tous les appareils que
nous achetons à 99% ils viennent de
l'étranger donc ils ont une sacrée
empreinte carbone et ils viennent
sacrément déséquilibré notre notre
balance commerciale alors que de
d'allonger la durée de vie de ces as de
ces appareils en plus de faire faire des
économies et de préserver la planète va
permettre la au sida
de recréer des emplois et des emplois
non délocalisables